the Passover is when the spirit of death
right passes over the house holes of
Egypt and it doesn't kill the firstborn
son as long as you put Lamb's blood
right on your door this is what Passover
is very high holiday High Jewish holiday
uh still celebrated Christian or Jewish
uh traditions
and so in Washington DC I've literally
watched people do a a metaphorical like
hedonistic Passover on their home so I
lived on Capitol Hill in a very bad
neighborhood where you like a couple
blocks from Jack pesobic uh had antifa
come after Jack that famous photo of
Jack like staring down antifa where they
were looking to tear down our Lincoln
Statue there's a statue of Abraham
Lincoln they wanted to tear it down
there were mobs putting you know nooses
around it to rip it down people put up
gay rights flags and BLM Flags in their
yards literally as like a please don't
come here thing I know these people
we're not uh some of them were
Republicans and they were not on board
with this they needed to wave these
flags and put the stuff up in order to
like stop the mobs from coming to their
Street